l'Occident au pose un front uni à
Vladimir Poutine il vient d'infliger à
la Russie des premières sanctions la
stratégie des 27 faire monter en
puissance et pénalités en cas d'escalade
que l'ensemble des ministres des
Finances européens travaillent en train
de sanction infiniment plus pénalisant
pour les intérêts russes pour les
intérêts du peuple russe et pour les
intérêts de l'économie russe le
Royaume-Uni les États-Unis ou encore le
Canada et l'Australie se sont
coordonnées avec l'Europe pour imposer
les sanctions à un rythme similaire mais
pour les Ukrainiens cette stratégie
n'est pas la bonne pour eux mieux vaut
prévenir que guérir
outre son clash en Chine
ping vole au secours de son allier russe
les autorités accusent les États-Unis
d'avoir un agenda guerrier qui aggrave
les tensions
la Chine s'oppose toujours à toute
sanctions unilatérale illégale
la sécurité de l'Europe sera-t-elle
mieux garantie grâce aux sanctions
américaines contre la Russie nous
espérons que les parties concernées
pourront y réfléchir sérieusement je
pense que nous devrions toujours essayer
de résoudre le problème par le dialogue
et la négociation
les premières sanctions déjà tombées
visent le secteur financier les députés
et certains oligarques russes ainsi que
le projet gazier Nord Stream